Premier ministre femme vie liberté en
semi-mars comment ne pas penser avec le
cœur lourd à toutes les femmes victimes
d'oppression dans le monde et plus
particulièrement aux iraniennes et aux
Afghans courageusement elle se battent
chaque jour au péril de leur vie pour
dénoncer des régimes qui ni leur
existence qui veulent les rendre
invisibles et qui les empêchent
d'accéder à la culture à l'école au
savoir et donc à leur émancipation
allant jusqu'à empoisonner des centaines
d'écolières en Iran leur force et leur
courage nous oblige à l'action à l'image
de ce qu'était l'apartheid raciale en
Afrique du Sud ces femmes sont victimes
d'un véritable apartheid sexuel en 1973
les Nations Unies adoptaient le texte de
la convention internationale sur
l'élimination et la répression du crime
d'apartheid qui a permis de prendre des
mesures sur le plan international en vue
d'éliminer de réprimer le crime
d'apartheid en ce 50e anniversaire de
cette convention la France sonorerait en
portant une initiative auprès des
Nations Unies et tendance cette
convention à l'aparthèse sexuelle en
proposant d'inclure ce type de
discrimination à l'article 2 définissant
le terme d'apartheid cette proposition
initiée par la Ligue du droit
international des femmes et soutenu par
de nombreux juristes et intellectuels
parmi lesquels sherine et Badi iranienne
prix Nobel de la paix alors la France
pays des droits de l'homme pays des
Lettres persanes aura-t-elle l'ambition
et le courage de porter cette demande
aux Nations Unies en y associant ses
partenaires européens